[Aplausos]
depois de uma infância vivida dentro do
quarto da empregada e desenhos animados
eu tive uma adolescência que oscilou
entre pontos de vendas de drogas e
livros
hoje eu frequento fundações casas
presídios fóruns sua gestora e
conselheira de um dos planos de um dos
projetos sociais mais lindos importantes
vivo amores e imagináveis
durante a faculdade eu tive a honra de
ser apresentada ao movimento da
literatura marginal e eu descobri que
dentro dos bairros conhecidos como os
mais perigosos da cidade de são paulo
como jardim angela brasilândia grajaú
existem pessoas que se encontram para
trocar a arte de declamar poesia
eu entrei no coletivo poetas do tietê e
nos dois últimos anos juntos realizamos
várias ações sociais saraus por todos os
cantos da cidade
a fundação dentro das fundações casas e
presídios e todas as vezes que vamos a
rua dá início a um trabalho que a gente
faz uma oração poética e eu quero
dividir essa oração com vocês neste
momento então eu pedi para troca eles
que se sentirem confortáveis em darem as
mãos alguém tiver ao seu lado eu vou
declamar uma poesia chamada armadura o
nome do poeta any brizante tenho medo de
me apegar ao chão de me acostumar a
viver por baixo e esquecer como se faz
para levantar mais medo de cair
eu perdi faz tempo eu tenho medo que meu
amor se acabe antes de ser feliz que
minha filha aguarde na memória a
lembrança de um pai que não sou eu
e que os meus amigos não me reconheço
quando nossas fotos ficarem velhas mais
medo de solidão
eu não tenho só coragem coragem é todo o
passo dado na direção oposta aquilo que
somos
quando nem mais o traiçoeiro fracasso
possa desonrar a nossa luta e até quando
o nosso maior inimigo passa a ser uma
conquista porque só não tem medo
quem não tem nada a perder e cá entre
nós deve ser muito idiota que não tem
nada a perder
defendo a sua alegria
defendo o seu amor defender a sua honra
defenda-se caso contrário ninguém jamais
lutar por você porque sentir medo é ser
humano mas ter coragem é carregar deus
dentro de si mas não esse deus fabricado
em becos vielas farmácias e
supermercados é carregar deus dentro de
si e em sua última no mantra armadura e
oração para uma vida inteira coragem
coragem coragem coragem coragem e
obrigada a ted
[Aplausos]